our troops deployed and governed by the
people we choose to rule our country to
a tremendous and courageous job they
work in sometimes appalling conditions
for long hours and make split-second
life-or-death decisions Northern Ireland
is one example of an extremely difficult
task up against an enemy too cowardly to
meet us head-on who tried to hide in the
shadows
sometimes even holding women and
children hostage most other family
members were instructed to drive bombs
as soldiers so that they could blow them
up but it's a soldiers who were working
to strict rules of engagement who face
investigations whilst the hoods the
backs of the back streets are handed out
letters of comfort in a time where our
leader of the Opposition appears to be
reluctant at announce certain terrorist
groups or even sing the national anthem
what hope of our veterans got and what
effect will it have on ourselves in
soldiers who at the back of their minds
will be thinking what could happen
instead of what they should be doing
when things turn noisy personally I
should seem to be judged by 12 and
carried by six what you just said for me
I wholly agree before we get into the
debate we should probably see what the
prime minister said about this in a PM
coop honest questions earlier this month
we have an unfair situation at the
moment the situation we have at the
moment is that the only people being
investigated for things that happened in
the part of these issues that happened
in the past are those in our armed
forces or those who served in law
enforcement in Northern Ireland that is
patently unfair terrorists are not being
investigated terrorists should be
investigated wants to see and I think
again Phil you're going to sign up to
that it's worth pointing out that was on
the 9th of May and to the best of my
knowledge we haven't moved that any
further forward I just have to read a
response from Shin Fane and it goes as
follows these remarks are deeply
insensitive the loss and pain of
hundreds of families who've been
bereaved by the British state forces
they've caused deep hurt and offence
could even undermine confidence in the
rule of law and the administration of
justice they are also demonstrably
untrue as has been evidenced by FISH
statistics and statements on legacy
investigation so says Shem phoned vice
present Michelle come straight back it's
time of a photograph of myself
of course you can all right thickness
photograph up well there's me as a young
fresh face soldier in Northern Ireland
about nineteen years old I believe okay
yeah 19 years old impactful of honest
information of what I shouldn't
shouldn't do a cake nineteen years old
right let's stick the other one up all
right right okay I was stood next to
that when that went pop right now it's
only for the buffoonery of the people
that laid the bomb that I wasn't kill
because I put it in the second-floor
with the public not the bottom for all
the pub or else Land Rover myself team
interpreter dog I'm Tina verse would
have gone flying across the world that's
attempted murder and that's the sort of
thing they're trying to bring the the
soldier that they are doing he's getting
done for attempted murder or the John
that's attempted murder okay we're not
stupid
all right and they're not I sense you're
not opposing you at all
and by the way seeing that early picture
of you we certainly know where all the
pies went we now come back there is
something called a military covenant by
which blokes like you and women go forth
and you put your lives on the line for
the defense of this country and you
carry out orders
we then should look after you we are not
fulfilling the militant covenant
we're not fulfilling with actions like
this and also story in the papers today
that they're now are needing money from
help for Heroes to back up some NHS
treatment because there isn't enough
money in the kitty to look after
returning service personnel it is that
is wrong it's just wrong and the
investigation but you would agree lastly
before I yield if a serving soldier had
committed a crime he or possibly she
does need to be investigated
we kept ordnance we loved everything we
did in we live in Ireland then we
stacked it all up so it would have been
looked at before the IRA or the other
terrorist or Russia did everything they
could get rid of any evidence and
destroy every bit confused because are
they suggesting that there should be a
statute of limitations on investigating
terrorism Babycham thing ya know it's
obtained of thing the opposite they
saying that the outer security forces
deaths in the province should be invest
continue to be investigated because
that's confusing as seven coming from
what I'm seeing seventy percent of the
killings I've actually been by
terrorists
the issue that Phil says there should be
a statute literally limitations these
anyway these soldiers were doing the
extract carrying out the instructions of
the state they are they should not be
investigating the murder anyway it's all
40 years ago and and it's gone it anyway
it made these arsons the poetry and I
pull the trigger and anger myself and
you don't get the privilege of sitting
in a high back lever chair okay two days
to make that decision you get a head
offense secretary Sir Michael Fallon
till completely agrees with you so can
we just hear what he said which is this
will not be this will not be just a
witch-hunt but a one-sided witch-hunt
so the IRA units did not keep records as
you say or operate within regular
command structures there should be a
clear distinction between our troops who
were doing their duty to the state and
risking their lives to protect others
and the terrorists who were happy to
blow up or maim entirely innocent
civilians Protestant and Catholic like
to kill people we went out looking to
protect people they went out at our gate
looking to kill people well that's the
difference so this whole thing is about
there's an inquiry it's not a public
inquiry so people's views are being
sought about whether there should be a
statute of limitations which would mean
that people who are serving in the
British Army would not basically it
would be an amnesty they would not be
able to be prosecuted and I am the
reason I'm confused is because four
trees are made to say and Michael Fallon
say this is one side it just doesn't
bear out when you look at the facts so
this is all about whether there should
be a new historical investigations unit
into these legacy crimes there currently
is already a historic inquiry team they
have been investigating more than 1,600
cases the vast majority are republican
killings the vast majority only 500 are
loyalist killings and do you want those
investable the republic ought to show
you of the legacy work that the Police
Service of Northern Ireland are
currently investigating only one-third
our killings by the army the rest our
Republic
and loyalist paramilitaries let's hear
what John tag has to say he's a victim
from both sides of this and then I'll
ask a question and the father who's
murdered by the army I'm a brother who's
murdered by the RAI I would feel that
from my perspective that I would want
exactly the same purpose I would feel
that each of them needs to be
investigated thoroughly at the same way
I know that's what I've been paying for
it so when I heard that I did a double
take because I had to listen carefully
again to ask the question this man
actually lost his father to the army our
army and his brother to the IRA so I
suppose he wants justice and my question
is who is it cuz I'm yet to discover
this who is it that's suggesting that
justice should only be one-sided and
there are traditionally cuted and not
the IR over Good Friday Agreement again
these letters of comfort right they were
told they don't need to be on the run
anymore you're okay they're under the
radar they won't be investigated anymore
they and I saw where our troops both are
beamers attracting this all uppity who's
brought it up again that only one side
will be prosecuted I'm not sure I
understand native possibly yeah yeah who
same both sides are being investigated
yet there's a suggestion that you know
the British Army should not be do you
know do you know which countries in the
world have an amnesty like this one
second from the safety of a TV studio in
West London we can say that right
whereas his mates they can check
probably to the minute what they did
they locked him in there you honestly
think you're gonna be able to track down
terrorists the same this will be draw
draw a line in the sand and let's we'll
move forward right know is what I'd like
to personally so are you saying so I
understand you saying that because of
Nick's point because the records are
meticulous for the soldiers and the IRA
terrorists didn't keep records
that's one point in argument yes
investigations they're not just a little
whose experience to people in a family
why is one victim where we gonna start
an investigation for that land row we've
just seen don't seems investigation of
this argument which is that the soldiers
who are in Northern Ireland were doing
what they were told to do by our guns
one of the things that would be being
invented and the terrorists are coming
out the door and actively trying to kill
people and break the law I wasn't trying
to break the law when I walk around
Northern Ireland with a gun I was trying
to hold the peace and I was acting under
the stringent regulation of the yellow
card and the orders from my offices and
steep areas above me okay so why should
I even if I had done something it was
deemed wrong why should I be facing
prosecution 40 years down the line and
the only countries that have an amnesty
for these kind of killings are Argentina
Chile what about what the Defense
Committee recommended in 2017 which was
a statute of limitations coupled with a
truth recovery mechanism to help
bereaved families in other words a Truth
and Reconciliation Committee that
doesn't involve a prosecutor those
soldiers I mean that's an official
suggestion and it strikes me as not the
only country South Africa had that model
and of course we all applauded Nelson
Mandela when he cooperated with that
model so perhaps we could you know help
the bereaved families like John Taylor
who's lost people on both sides of this
conflict while not going after people
like you that served our country